[Music]
let's go to we're back jack i finally
get to say it let's go talk to jack in
michigan what's up jack
hi john how are you doing good man
what's up so
uh basically my girlfriend has
a lot of guy friends basically and
she tends to be very nice with them and
it often makes me
jealous and kind of bitter a little bit
and uncomfortable when i
see her sitting next to them and hanging
out with them and
i guess my question is how can i deal
with
getting jealous and how can i overcome
that
that's a good question man how long have
you all been dating
uh we've been together almost
about a year and a half
okay um
have you have you sat down and talked to
her about it
yeah we've we've talked about this
before how'd that go
it went pretty good um
i mean she's still gonna have those
friends out there
it went great except nothing changed
that's awesome
um so the conversation was good and so
here's the hard
truth i'm gonna give you okay
you can't change her and you can't
change her friendships the only thing
you can deal with here is you
you can decide
um i
i can't date somebody who spends a lot
of time with other guy friends who goes
out with him who hangs out who like is
always texting with them and always
calling them
who may have had you know intimate
relationships with them in the past they
may have dated in the past i can't do
that
and so i'm going to make the decision
since of of stating my boundaries firmly
and clearly and kindly not because
you're a jerk
and she can say great well my boundaries
are i am not going to date somebody that
tells me i can't have friends of the
opposite sex
and then the choice is yours man
to uphold your boundaries or to cave
into your boundaries it sounds like
you're going to be miserable
um
i don't i don't think i'm miserable
really i just
i think it really is a neat thing
because i really trust her and she
doesn't hang out with them alone or
anything she's it'll always be in a
group setting
yeah but it makes you jealous and you
wonder what's going on and you wonder
why not you
and you yeah i guess yeah that's misery
that's that's that's the definition of
misery
uh and so
i
sounds like she's been pretty clear with
her boundary
what i don't want you to do man is to
make a choice to be miserable over a
girlfriend that's a
that's a heartbreaking choice but it's a
strange choice right
yeah
because you're going to get married and
this will stay the same
and then you'll have your first kid and
this will stay the same
is that fair
yeah i get what you're saying she's
she's really great about it and she
understands it i know but it doesn't
matter because you're hurting
yeah
and i don't have one ounce of ill will
towards her she's allowed to do whatever
she wants
and she has chosen
to keep her guy friends over making her
current boyfriend
have peace let letting him have peace
that's her choice she made she's allowed
to do that she's a grown-up that's the
boundary she drew fantastic
i think trying to make yourself be less
jealous is an exercise in futility you
can become more mature
right you can you know what i mean like
you can be not bothered by immature
things
but trying to say hey it's a big deal to
me that you don't hang out with other
guys while we're dating
and her saying it's a big deal to me
that i have all the autonomy and freedom
i want in a dating relationship cool
then we're not going to work
no matter how nice and kind and
everybody is
you went quiet on me man what are you
thinking
i'm trying to think of what to think
yeah it's hard
so here's what i'd recommend you do and
i recognize there's so much
wound up in this like you love this
person
yeah yeah
you do
she probably loves you too right
yeah yeah
and she has her boundaries and you have
yours
and
the beauty of that's why dating is
important right because you say hey
these things matter to me and you get to
practice those things and you get to
people run up against them and you see
if they hold i had some obnoxious
boundaries when i first started like
it's got to be like this it's gotta be
like this i was wrong on almost all of
them dude i was an idiot and it's the
ones that held firm they held really
firm
and such that is right and every
relationship's gonna i'm telling like
on the long end you're she's playing
with fire there right and you know that
everybody knows that
um
and i don't have an again i don't have
any ill will torture at all um it's
playing with fire and your heart is bro
i mean the alarms going off inside your
body are probably telling you the truth
but you can't control her and so you
have to be true to you especially when
you're dating this is much messier much
harder when people are married
um man you've set a boundary and i'm
gonna suggest you honor that boundary so
i want you to write these things down
write down what you believe write down
your boundaries write down what your
needs are and hear me say this jack you
deserve them
even if that means telling somebody that
you love
i love you
and
there's going to be a period at the end
of our sentence
that's going to hurt for everybody right
there's no way that people don't hurt
moving forward you're going to hurt just
being in it you're going to hurt getting
out of it there's going to be hurt you
get to choose which hurt it's going to
be
and um when you're dating i'm gonna
really strongly suggest to everybody out
there
um be true to your boundaries be true to
them